many years later after after i got into  talkies I was asked to become the  president of United Artists I was well  aware that the founders of that studio  were among the greatest names of the  silent era DW Griffith Charlie Chaplin  Mary Pickford and Douglas Fairbanks so I  wasn't surprised when one of the first  calls I received in my new job was from  kevin brownlow my first thought was that  Kevin was going to urge me to return to  my roots and make an entire slate of  silent films but it turned out that his  reason for calling was much more  personal a film that Kevin had made in  the 1960s called it happened here was  still controlled by you a he'd been  trying for years to get the rights back  and he asked me if I could help and so  in one of my first official acts at UA I  was able to give back to kevin brownlow  the rights to his film a small thank you  to someone who had done so much for  those four founders of united artists  and for so many others of the silent era  you